i don't know if that's terrifying or
what that is because if life is
everywhere
why is intelligent life not everywhere
why i mean you've talked about that most
likely
alien civilizations if they are out
there
they would likely be far ahead of us
the ones that would actually communicate
with us yes
and that
um
again one of those things is both
exciting and terrifying you've mentioned
that they're likely not to be of
biological nature
well i think
that's important of course again it's a
speculation but uh
in speculating about
um intelligent life and i
i take the search seriously in fact i
chair the
committee that the um russian american
investor yuri milner supports looking
for
intelligent life he's putting 10 million
dollars a year into a better equipment
and getting time on telescopes to do
this and so i think it's worthwhile even
though i i don't hold my breath for
success it's it's very exciting but but
that does
lead me to wonder what
might be detected and um
i think
well we don't know we've got to be
reminded about anything we have no idea
what it will be and so any anomalous
objects or even some strange shiny
objects in the solar system or anything
we've got to keep our eyes open for but
i think um if we
ask
what
about a um
planet like the earth where evolution
had taken more the same track
then as you say it wouldn't be
synchronized um if it
had lagged behind then of course it
would not have got too
advanced life
but it may
have had a head start it may have formed
on a plant around an older star okay but
then let's ask what would see
it's taken nearly four billion years
from the first life to us
and we've now got this technological
civilization
which
could make itself
detectable um to any alien live
aliens out there um
but i think most people would say
that this
civilization
of flesh and blood creatures in the
collective civilization may not last
more than a few hundred years more i
think that the
that people may some people say
it will um kill itself off um but
i'm more optimistic and i would say
that sir
what we're going to have in future
is um
no longer the slow darwinian selection
but we're going to have what i call
secular intelligent design which will be
humans
designing um
their progeny to be better adapted to
where they are
and uh
if they go to mars or something
somewhere they're badly adapted and they
want to adapt a lot and so
they will adapt um
but there may be some limits to what
could be done with flesh and blood and
so they may become
largely electronic
um
download their brains and have and be
electronic entities and if they're
electronic
then what's important is that they're
near immortal
and also they won't unless they want to
be on a planet with an atmosphere or
gravity they may go off into the blue
yonder and they and if they're near
immortal they won't be daunted by
interstellar travel taking a long time
and so um
if
if we
looked at what would happen
on the earth in the next millions of
years
then there may be these electronic
entities which have been sent out and
are now far away from the earth
but still sort of burping away in some
in some fashion to be detected um and so
uh this um this therefore leads me to
think that um if there
was another
planet which had evolved like the earth
and was ahead of us
it wouldn't
be synchronized so we wouldn't see a
flesh and blood civilization but we
would see
these electronic progeny as it were um
and then this raises another question
because um
there's the famous argument against
there being um uh lots of aliens out
there which is that they would um come
and invade us and eat us or something
like that you know
that's a common idea uh which so fairly
is attributed to i've been the first to
say um and i think there's a um escape
clause to that because these um entities
yeah would be uh say that they evolved
by secular intelligence designed by
their predecessors and then designed by
us um and uh um
whereas darwinian selection requires two
things
it requires aggression
and intelligence
this future intel design
may favor intelligence because that's
what they were designed for but it may
not favor aggression
and so these future entities they they
may be um
sitting deep thoughts
thinking deep thoughts
um
and uh not
being at all expansionists so they could
be out there
yeah um and we can't refute their
existence in the way the fermi paradox
is supposed to refute their existence
because um these would not be aggressive
or expansionist well maybe evolution
requires competition not aggression and
i wonder if competition can take forms
that are non-expansionary
so you can still have fun competing yeah
yeah in the space of ideas
which maybe primarily adobe philosophers
perhaps yeah
[Laughter]
in in a way right it's a it's an
intellectual exercise versus a sort of
violent exercise
you